A little bit later, I'm going to be doing
a deeper, sort of more detailed dove into
yesterday's very, very unusual press briefing
that Donald Trump gave.
But I want to focus in specifically on something
for a moment where Donald Trump actually said
something that is completely correct, sort
of.
But he said it for completely self-centered
and greedy reasons.
And unfortunately, some on the left have kind
of fallen for it.
And it's really disturbing to see.
So let me kind of set this all up for you.
Donald Trump sort of nailed and exposed the
military industrial complex at its core during
yesterday's press briefing.
I'm going to play the clip for you.
The only problem is that he seems to have
no awareness of the fact that he has contributed
to growing to feeding that same military industrial
complex that he criticized yesterday.
And, of course, the reason that Donald Trump
said this was to try to make himself look
better.
That's always Donald Trump's priority.
So let's go in steps as we should.
Here is Donald Trump explaining why some of
the top people at the Pentagon, as he claims,
do not like him in reference to the story
about Donald Trump allegedly saying troops
who died in combat are losers and suckers.
Here is Donald Trump.
Biden shipped away our jobs, threw open our
borders and sent our youth to fight in these
crazy, endless wars.
And it's one of the reasons the military I'm
not saying the military is in love with me.
The soldiers are the top people in the Pentagon
probably aren't because they want to do nothing
but fight wars so that all of those wonderful
companies that make the bombs and make the
planes and make everything else stay happy.
But so this actually is a critique that makes
a lot of sense.
Donald Trump points out that part of how the
Pentagon operates and part of how the military
operates is impossible to extricate.
It's impossible to separate from defense and
military contractors.
I don't remember a Republican president and
even many Democratic presidents so clearly
calling this out.
Good for Trump.
He said something that is mostly correct.
Now, there's a couple of problems with this.
The main problem, of course, is that everything
Donald Trump has done has actually fed the
military industrial complex.
You might think, well, hey, Trump's right.
He didn't get us into any wars as he defines
them.
He's not the war president, but he's certainly
done some bombing.
But put the bombing aside for a second.
Donald Trump has bragged his entire presidency
about all of the arms deals and purchases
that he has made.
He's bragged about how much he sold to Saudi
Arabia and the deal he brokered for American
military contractors to Saudi Arabia the entire
term that he has come up with of refilling
the cupboards.
He claims the cupboards were left empty by
Barack Obama.
He's talking about military equipment.
He regularly brags about having rebuilt the
military bigger and better and more powerful
than ever before.
That is Trump feeding the military industrial
complex that he sounded like he was criticizing
there.
So this was sort of like a rare moment of
clarity for Trump in some sense.
But it's for completely greedy personal reasons
that he stumbled across something that's sort
of true and he's part of the problem.
The reason that Donald Trump said this is
not to actually critique the military industrial
complex.
In fact, everything he's done has supported
it.
Trump was trying to explain away why somebody
at the military or the Pentagon might say
something negative about him.
That is all that he cares about.
And very sadly, some on the left have fallen
for it.
I my instinct is that it's the sort of Tulsi
Gabbard crowd.
They have fallen for this and they are now
saying Trump is well to the left of anybody,
you know, left of Obama left.
But no, Trump isn't actually calling out the
military industrial complex.
Trump has bragged for four years about feeding
and fueling the military industrial complex.
And then my my last thought on this.
The military industrial complex isn't even
really generals who want to start wars.
And they're mad at Trump because they won't
let him he won't let them start a war.
That's not really the way it happens, the
way that the military industrial complex stuff
happens, the mind the revolving door of money
is lobbyists pushing Congress for pork and
Congress doing it because they want donations
and all of these other projects for their
districts.
That's really the military industrial complex.
So, yes, Trump is right to some degree.
But the idea that that's how it works.
Ignoring the whole lobbying industrial complex
really misses a big piece of it.
So, okay.
You know, let let's let's praise Trump to
the degree that he deserves praise.
But let's understand that he is a huge part
of the problem and is only saying this because
he's trying to explain away the Atlantic story,
which has, of course, since been corroborated
by the Associated Press and by Fox News and
by CNN.
We actually do.
I don't believe that this is being overly
cynical.
I believe it's being realistically skeptical.
Tell me if you think I'm wrong.
Let's now look at some other outrageous moments
from yesterday's press briefing.